Mariah Mariah Carey steps out in New  York City taking control of exactly what  she wants to say to the paparazzi  bracelet Thank You something new  delivering amazing diva moment after  diva moment who is one person that's  qualified to sing at your wedding  nobody PG was with the star as she  promoted her upcoming docu-series of the  NBC Universal upfront Monday morning and  she continued being the diva we know and  love while talking about her upcoming  nuptials it's gonna be a small thing  already  oh one more moment with Mariah this trip  on the carpet at the upfronts losing her  Louboutin that was a classic that was a  classic piece moment